what's happening reject nation greg and
john here today we are going to watch
ourselves on b9 season one episode 18
called the apartment guys thank you so
much for being here if you enjoy our
reaction of course please hit that like
button also you know full length watch
the logs where you stick up with the
time code for b99 or over at our patreon
page cover a whole bunch of shows over
there with the same tier options for
reaction highlights and or watch along
included lastly big thanks to
predominantly now there's highlights for
us dude you'll be one hell of a
detective inside of the brooklyn
nine-nine police department i'll tell
you that much let's get into it
so again your alibi is a mysterious
stranger handed you the gun made you put
your prints on it robbed the store and
then hid the gun in your underpants well
yeah if you say it like that it don't
sound believable
pour it on the finley murder oh yeah i
looked it over nice work good thanks dad
what
why is everyone staring at me you just
called captain holt dad he said thanks
dad uh
do you see me as a father figure peralta
no if anything i see you as a bother
figure cause you're always bothering me
i wouldn't
show your father some respect
no no no no jacob
jacob called vivian mom once and she's
my fiance guys jump on that boyle has
psychosexual issues old news
daddy is not on the table here but you
did call him dad dude you shut up you've
done nothing but lie since you got here
all right all right i was lying about
the holdup but the dad thing
you want to talk about it later over a
game of catch
i'd like that
[Laughter]
i i want to see them play catch i hope
that does happen
i couldn't tell if holt was mocking him
or being
i know
he's probably a little flattered you
know
ought to be
thank you for coming in on your day off
health evaluations san diego why
is
also please stay out of the way of the
weekend squad i hate the weekend squad
i'm pumped for these evaluations sir i
feel like a proud mama hen whose baby
chicks have learned to fly interesting
analogy sergeant chickens are famously
bad at flying
[Laughter]
is there any way i can borrow 430 000
why on earth do you need that much money
i need to buy my apartment i need to
secure a loan by the end of the day uh
so should we do a wire transfer
let's just do cash shouldn't you be
asking somebody else for that kind of
money like a bank take it from the
evidence locker
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
we grew up together we used to hang out
there every day after school that's
right because there is no one to look
after us peralta i will not give you a
cool half mill because you had a
slightly sad childhood
nana made me the intelligent sensuous
woman i am today weird way to describe
she knew what was up
[Music]
they never like anyone else outside of
them nope
it's not a welcoming group
sometimes detective kearns and i leave
presents for each other
i hate him anna's face garbage why don't
you just tell him to stop shaving at his
desk next time i catch him shaving i'm
going to punch him so hard in the mouth
he fights his own heart oh
could that be why he and i was doing it
oh yeah you could be right yeah
it is always so crazy coming back here
remember when nana got cable i got to
say i'm psyched to be hanging like this
old school styles styles with a z i
forgot they were related
yeah completely
so talk to me goose how we looking sexy
but not like we're trying too hard like
sure we're trying but it's almost
effortless yeah no i knew all of that i
meant the money
my first impression is that you have a
debilitating spending problem okay you
also purchased olympus has fallen on
demand 12 times jerry butler how much do
i have to cut back in order to keep this
place infinity percent
technically speaking you're bankrupt
kiddo
[Music]
wow bankrupt
this is so unfair i've lived in this
building 15 years and then all of a
sudden they decide they're going co-op
with zero warning it seems illegal they
didn't tell you this was happening oh
they tried
let's check the mail tub mail tub nope
no
no
oh my god jesus
oh this is giving me a headache
nice clawfoot tub which i will never
throw my mail into again
sir i know we got off to a weird start
so to get things back on track i'd like
to bring in santiago next and she's had
a great year you wanted to see me sirs
said bring in santiago next or something
about a san diego nest
i understand from a lip reading session
last week
oh god
for you i have just one question
what is your biggest
flaw
ooh
oh amy working too hard caring too much
kissing ass got it something entirely
different
not willing to acknowledge your flaws
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yeah the fill is locked with shaving
cream and loose hair i like it
cannot believe i am considering a
non-violent option and i know just where
to get a bundle of loose hair
okay answered my question
yep
i just need enough to show the co-op
board i can make a down payment at the
bank how about twenty thousand dollars
two bags of zitty
that i can do
he is a sea witch in disguise do not
sing into his shell i have no idea what
you're talking about right now
oh my god oh no
oh
please i hope that's the right locker
hurry
my cold-blooded vengeance
and now
the resistance
a magnificent bag of hair
it's perfect
oh no he's bonding with gina i'm tom
selleck park my chopper on the beach
i'm a bully goat
that's gross stop quite gross yeah
oh yeah
i think i swallowed a bunch of stranger
hair
is there any way we can move it to the
sunday after eight years from next
friday
based on your judgy eyes i am going to
take back my dynamite um
oh is that going to be able to return
the body
out of here nope okay okay
oh
no gina is gonna be the key
this isn't the only apartment in the
city we'll find you a new one you're
right i mean maybe we'll find a great
place not a girl in a cooler
neighborhood that's right girl maybe
i'll even have a cute neighbor get it
girl
i know why you weren't happy with my
self-evaluation you didn't want me to
say flaws that were actually positive so
what's your biggest flaw i'm too
competitive prone to jealousy bit of a
killjoy
every now and then i smoke a cigarette
is that what you're looking for
people-pleasing baby oh no santiago and
b-flat you're disappointed okay
people it's also pet friendly really
do they allow cats i can't tell if
you're being sarcastic okay
[Music]
oh murphy bed
voila nope
ceilings so many windows gina the toilet
is in the middle of the living room
it does build a closet around it oh my
god oh my god
not today i've been spending all my
breaks on the phone with my wife nancy
we've been having marital problems right
cause you're hygiene no i wish
now about a year ago she fell down the
stairs and broke her back oh no now
she's addicted to painkillers oh no oh
no cause i want to help her you know i
guess i just love her so much
she's refusing treatment oh
we got into it again last night i went
out for some fresh air but i forgot to
close the door and our dog cinnamon got
it that was a photo of the dog cinnamon
got hit by a drunk driver oh no
no
said her suffering was unending and
terrible no
i'm sorry just vending a little i
appreciate it of course
anything for a good friend like you
charles can i see you for a minute yep
my first question is
why are the two of you doing this
self-evaluation together scully doesn't
handle pressure well oh my
combined total of 14 arrests
would have been 20 but well i got 14.
i'm trying to hurt him when you grab the
hair it breaks apart the key is if you
use your hands like uh scoopers oh jesus
no
no no
i'm sure there's a reasonable
explanation for this sir uh we
accidentally dropped all our loose hair
and shaving cream
hasn't detective low hank been through
enough he just got diagnosed with
prostate cancer no
no
oh
oh no
oh
but what if i bought this apartment
i've saved up money and i'm looking for
a real estate opportunity i could give
you a fair rent because i would be your
landlady you be my landlady you're gina
you call gum the dentist
i'm glad that i still own this place
because i can happily invite you to
leave
grow up jake grill up jake
i take back the z
no
just checking out my new bedroom
feels like scoliosis and smells like 10
million butts take it your apartment
thing didn't work out when did everyone
decide to become an adult i mean i know
you were born in your 50s but come on
gina just offered to buy nana's
apartment as a real estate opportunity
and become my landlady jake i know she
was just trying to help but we've known
each other since we were kids and now i
find out she's been saving all these
years jake
the person that i'm really mad at is
myself for screwing this whole thing up
i gotta talk to gina thanks for helping
what would you say holt thinks my
biggest flaw is who cares what hole
thinks
what's most important is what i think
your biggest flaw is and there are so
many to choose from too competitive
your shame cigarettes oh my god but your
biggest flaw is you suck at throwing
away your secret lists
[Music]
she cares too much when people think
there's too much to please
she wants that approval you were
completely unfair to my squad today
santiago is one of your best detectives
and all you wanted to do was play mind
games with her scully and hitchcock only
arrested 14 people but that's eight more
than last year they only arrested six
people last year
sit down i'm gonna do your evaluation
now oh oh you're right i have been hard
on the squad you're a good leader and
just the fact that you're willing to
stand up for them is one of the reasons
you have every right to feel like um
what was it you said this morning proud
mama hen sir a proud mama
[Laughter]
go terry
i'm watching oprah's legends ball which
is what i do every time a close friend
hurts my feelings i came here to
apologize
close friends not related yeah they just
grew up together but now we know
also you should buy an anna's place not
for me you should live there you love
that apartment and you said so yourself
it's a great investment i actually ran
the numbers i'd keep paying the same
amount of rent and you would turn a
small profit it's a starter apartment
and it's my fault for starting when i'm
33.
you have a deal all right sexy
yes
awesome
is there a reason you're interrupting me
mid-soup yeah
so i asked peralta what you thought my
biggest flaw was and he said
who cares what holt thinks that's not
surprising he's very disrespectful
i should be more confident in my own
judgment and i am so sure of that
i don't even care if you think i'm right
evaluation over
enjoy your soup
[Music]
[Laughter]
master plan yes sir
yeah yeah
this was a deep
episode
about looking into oneself and seeing
how they really feel about thyself
underneath the surface and not only that
how that affects others too
and looking at what's really going on
underneath the surface how well do you
know yourself and
how quick are you to judge others
before getting caught up in your own
opinions you know absolutely like with
the guy at the desk
which was really funny how they did that
that was hilarious how they handled that
that was that i was actually surprised i
was like oh damn i didn't see this this
little bit coming that he's actually
going through a super tough time and
none of that shape because he's still
shaving at the
uh that's still a bad habit i would be
very selfish i would in that moment i'd
be if i didn't do the prank
i don't care what you're going through
you don't shave into my keyboard i would
go that far i would just be like i get
you're going through a hard time
you're still shaving and blowing it into
my keyboard
i think but you can do one without the
other yes i respect what you're going
through and i understand
and i have much compassion for you
same time
you don't have to shave at my desk and
blow it into the keyboard because then
it makes it harder for me to truly
empathize where you're going from
because i'm so distracted by your
disgusting inconsiderate habits that
sound like they've been going on before
any of this stuff with your wife started
happening
so cut the [ __ ] would you yes i would go
down that path but because of the prank
actually
but for the way that whole thing went
down was so funny dude oh yeah and i
loved i mean i think it was probably
engineered to have you going oh god
don't make it the wrong locker
yeah it goes beyond that to no it was
absolutely
the right locker because they had the
face of the his wife and the dog there
so that's why i was like i think this is
the wrong locker yeah yeah absolutely
and i mean just the way he played that
the way they played that and what that
did for charles and rosa just like as a
you know i imagine that someday their
romance is gonna spark off again after
he
you know they learn how to spend time
together in moments like these but like
them just like getting to bounce off
each other and be on a scheme together i
thought was really fun
yeah and then with uh peralta learning
you know what actually for peralta gina
it was i i liked uh chelsea pereira's
performance here she got to have a lot
more
sincere moments and sincerity that was
never undercut by genisms yeah she felt
like a just a character this time yeah
rather than like you know your your
saucy punchline yeah she seemed like uh
i believe that she would have a lot of
money based off of what we've
established about her character
uh you know how crafty she is and then
at the same time like those scenes where
she's sitting down where like
you know peralta is being super childish
but gina is like trying to really
connect i was i really believed her in
that moment and it i wasn't like where's
the joke like i started actually getting
into
uh the way you were seeing this real
caring side because this is touching on
her childhood as well it was nice you
know and then like with peralta dealing
with like money situations i think a
spending habit joke they keep coming
back is so funny
but um it also makes them a little bit
more relatable because i think most
people in their 30s have spending
problems or at least when you're 20s you
probably learn about the time of your
thirties but uh spending problems and
then uh being broke you know even as
this like you know cop who thinks very
highly of himself and how good he is
just adds more to his childish character
but you know having money problems very
relatable thing for pretty much most
people in the world yeah absolutely that
apartment's going to look like yours
when you when you get your own place
which gina's or or the grandma one the
grandma one that's the way how peralta
doesn't have all my massage chairs
and all that mail and the bathtub i
don't know where else to put the mail
now nah man i open up my mail and i did
get rid of a lot of it now awesome yeah
new new day
but yeah no i i really like it's funny
yeah i really liked him and uh gina
together and just what that whole plot
line was you know it was yeah the first
time where you do have like i feel like
i i flash back a little bit to the one
where uh uh rosa and amy are helping her
out because that's a little bit more
like oh gina's really a character this
time and then to have also yeah that
connection that we had both forgotten
about about like them growing up like
that's another thing that adds just to
the overall strength of the ensemble i
think and yeah it was like a nice
opportunity for gina to prove that she
is quite resourceful in a lot of ways
and that there are certain things that
yeah i probably would go to you about in
particular and then on the last you know
sort of third of the episode i thought
the you know self-evaluation was a great
tactic because i mean a it's designed
absolutely to get a character like amy
ticking but also it then opens you up to
just a whole bunch of fun little
vignettes and stuff like that so you
know like everybody gets a moment in the
room to do some kind of kooky evaluation
and then you have the other two plot
lines going you know yeah
and also amy's learning lesson too about
you know
think about caring too much what people
think people pleasing and all that
is something i personally
have never understood of why people
would even think about that idiots a
bunch of just idiots don't you know that
no one else's opinion about you really
matters
just yourself you know just
you define yourself and you don't need
to compare yourself to others or you
don't need to look for validation from
people yeah so i i just don't get it
like
that's one quality in human beings i've
never
understood yeah like what use is there
and people pleasing you know like what
are you going to achieve by even trying
that nothing worthwhile
but please if you enjoy this video i
hope that you can make it better next
time if you didn't i hope it gets a lot
of likes and uh because one there's like
even one whoa that drives me
as me and zen like what did i do wrong
what did i do wrong we gotta tear it all
down
i'll see like so many like loving so
leave a comment too and what you thought
of our reaction because you know it's
it's fun going through the comments
because you know it's mainly really
positive but then i find that i only
respond to the one negative one and i'm
like i gotta prove them wrong absolutely
or find a way to turn their displeasure
into pleasure
it always makes me question myself i'm
like man what do i have to change about
me to make this person happy
you know just just whatever's in the
text of their comment
usually damn it just take every note you
can that's the important part that's how
you grow in life is you just take every
piece of feedback to heart take it
personally and then you know try to act
upon it every moment you can i already
do that well then you're on your way man
you're so much further ahead than a lot
of people yeah
but weirdly you know whenever i watch a
show to the show i can never identify
with santiago no i don't get it
guys what'd you think about this episode
and subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell smash smash smash
that like button last but not least
jason dolan i got a shout out jason
dolan because if there's one person on
our patreon who i feel like i'm always
trying to people please
it's jason this is jason he helped us
out and when we were in a real tough
pickle a while back he he got us a
camera out of the kindness of his heart
broke down in tears now anytime jason
wants something even in the slightest
regard no matter what it is
i instantly feel the need to keep him
happy
and i feel like he's going to use that
against me if i ever upset him even in
the slightest
so
jason i think
you are a great human being and i never
want to upset you and you could always
talk to me and i will listen
without any
a hidden agenda because you are just
such a a a
kindred spirit
and please don't ask me to pay for the
camera now
please
please
jason why would
he want us to go broke
he wants to be homeless jason is that
what you want
you took this in another direction oh no
hold on i can fix it
[Music]